j'ai été violée
j'ai été agressée sexuellement par un
grand oncle qui était en fait l'oncle de
ma mère arnaud gallet a souvent raconté
les sévices qu'il a subis mais chaque
fois il est pris de la même émotion
j'avais 8 ans à l'époque quand les faits
se sont produits la première fois ce
grand temps qu'il était prêtre
missionnaire il venait en france
enfin quand ils séjournaient en france
en fait ils dormaient chez nathan et mes
parents l'occident mère dans ma chambre
est systématiquement à chacun de ses
passages entre 8 et 11 ans en fait les
faits se sont produits sous le toit de
mes parents dans ma chambre
arnaud n'a jamais protesté encore moins
dénoncé son agresseur vous pouvez faire
ce qu'il voulait de moi d'ailleurs très
rapidement en fait il a usé de de
stratégie pour parvenir à ses fins c'est
à dire que dans un premier temps
il m'a par exemple il a pris ma main
pour la mettre sur ma main pour la
mettre sur son sexe et c est en fait un
tas de choses qui me rendait je pense
mal à l'aise qui faisait qu' il n'y a
pas besoin d'user de force ou de
contrainte mais que mme en tant
qu'enfant je pense de tf1 s'était pas
normal donc j'étais complètement
tétanisés par rapport à ça arnaud a
aussi gardé le silence quand ce qui
était un jeu en famille s'est transformé
en cauchemar
j'ai eu mes cousins qui l'aîné qui avait
15 ans quand j'avais 12 ans l'aîné a dit
tiens je te montrer cet été une femme ce
que je te ferai mais du coup il m'a
sauté dessus m'a mis au sol son frère
m'a pris des poignets et
et le plus grand donc miné son sac sans
la bouche de force son histoire elle est
banale vous dire à arnaud celle d'une
proie facile dans une famille
dysfonctionnelle où il subissait la
violence de son père moi j'ai pas envie
de leur nuit en france la publication de
la familia grande et le récit de camille
kouchner qui dévoile l'inceste et les
viols subis par son frère jumeau à leurs
adolescents
on pourrait en effet croire à la
banalité de son récit la sortie du livre
a provoqué un raz-de-marée de
témoignages sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le mot-clic mitu inceste des milliers de
victimes ont trouvé le courage de braver
la honte le tabou
j'ai été violée par mon père et mes
frères mois par ma mère j'avais deux ans
c'est une plaie qui ne se refermera
jamais je mourrai avec je le sais
témoigne-t-on en 140 caractères
dans son livre camille kouchner exposé
olivier duhamel son beau père professeur
de droit respecté un intellectuel d'une
grande famille de gauche un homme
puissant admirez de son cercle familial
qui aurait violé pendant plusieurs mois
son beau fils il ya vraiment la
découverte d'une d'une mécanique de loi
du silence de déni est la découverte que
bien que tout le monde sache ce qui
s'est passé mais c'est bah rien n'a été
fait et rien n'a été dit donc cette loi
du silence c'est vraiment un élément qui
qui a marqué les gens là franchement les
c'est un peu comme si
les gens se mettaient à re vraiment
ouvrir les yeux sur 7 sur cette réalité
là et à ne pas la contourner la
psychiatre muriel salmona et spécialiste
des victimes de violences sexuelles
elle-même a subi l'inceste à l'âge de
six ans elle dénonce ce qu'elle qualifie
d' impunité effarante en france et
milite pour des changements dans la loi
notamment en faveur de l'abandon des
délais de prescription
le cerveau des enfants est encore plus
vulnérables enfin ils sont encore plus
vulnérables à la fois parce qu'ils sont
tout petits et parce que leur cerveau va
être beaucoup plus vulnérables et avant
développer beaucoup plus de ce qu'on
appelle des amnésies traumatique qui
sont en fait des mécanismes de
sauvegarde que cerveau met en place
quand on est tout le temps confrontés à
une situation de violence ou au contexte
de la violence ou à l'agresseur pendant
des années une amnésie traumatique c'est
précisément ce qui est arrivé à arnaud
qui ne s'est souvenu d'avoir été violée
par ses cousins qu'une fois en thérapie
à l'âge de 27 ans je crois qu en soit
cette amnésie devrait pouvoir servir de
preuve
cet événement était tellement violent
pour moi que mon cerveau a complètement
déconnecté mais complètement
sérieusement rappelé pur l'avocate
isabelle steyer crois que tout le
système doit admettre que l'inceste ne
peut pas être traité comme un crime au
même titre que les autres
en france on a neuf à faire sur dix qui
sont classées sans suite selon les
dossiers d'inceste cela signifie que
d'abord on n'a absolument pas les bons
critères la bonne grille de lecture la
bonne analyse pour valider le discours
de l'enfant
on a à peu près rien et que ensuite
évidemment comme on est dans un huis
clos familial et que l'on dénonce des
faits qui ne se produisent ni dans la
rue ni devant témoin on a pas de témoins
donc tout va être porté par cette parole
de l'enfant
on vous écoute vous croire et vous ne
serez plus jamais seul
à ces paroles de soutien prononcé par le
président emmanuel macron le
gouvernement affirme vouloir ajouter un
nouveau crime qui interdirait toute
pénétration sexuelle sur un mineur de
moins de 15 ans en france il n'y a pas
pour l'instant d'âge minimal de
consentement l'exécutif se dit aussi
ouvert à revoir les délais de
prescription qui sont actuellement de 30
ans après la majorité de la victime mais
pas à les éliminer complètement
l'imprescriptibilité est aujourd'hui
réservé aux crimes contre l'humanité et
puis notre préoccupation bien sûr déjà
exprimée par des avocats des magistrats
que fait-on 50 ans après et c'est le
crime est imprescriptible
comment a t'on encore une preuve ces
questions simples promeneurs son grand
oncle est aujourd'hui décédé mais l'été
dernier arnaud a déposé une plainte
contre ces deux cousins 21 ans près sa
majorité s'est inventé un an après les
faits pourtant arnaud travaille à la
protection de l'enfance
il connaît les procédures mais il en
était incapable plus tôt c'est donc
l'adulte qu'il est devenu aujourd'hui
qui parle au nom de l'enfant qu'il était
un enfant qui malgré son silence parlait
avait envoyé des messages qu'on aurait
dû voir un enfant qu'on aurait dû
protéger il le fait pour lui et pour
toutes les victimes qui ne peuvent
toujours pas
c'est aussi pour qu'on lutte contre
cette impunité complète dans les
connaissent toutes les victimes
enfin que tous connaissent pas mon
l'impunité que connaissent les auteurs
de violences sexuelles
parce que tout simplement les procédures
sont aussi très longue parce que le
processus déjà pour pouvoir déposer
plainte
il est périlleux et même continent on y
arrive on se demande à quel moment parce
que la justice réellement réponse et
c'est terrible de dire ça mais à quel
moment la justice répond pas